this week I've got one of the most
exciting guests I'm ridiculously excited
to introduce James Caan you probably
already know who he is James Caan
started his first business with nothing
but a yellow pages book inside a broom
cupboard he's now one of Britain's most
respected businessmen become a household
name I think he's probably most famous
for being one of the Dragons and Dragons
Den or former dragons he's got a massive
heart there's a lot of charity workers
built a school in Pakistan and also a
similar Times best seller of the book
the real deal James Caan which is easy
biography which I highly recommend
checking out so James thank you so much
for having me and letting me interview
you on the show
you've done a lot of things as an
entrepreneur over the years what would
you say the thing that you're most proud
of is I think for me probably when I
received my CBE so as a humble
entrepreneur you know started life as
you say in a broom cupboard and waking
up one day on my way to Buckingham
Palace and you know the kind of whole
formality the ceremony the palace when
you walk up in you know you see Andrew
and you get the CBE it was just the most
humbling experience because you know
when you come from nothing it's quite
you know it's quite a daunting and
humbling experience so probably I think
receiving my CB at Buckingham Palace was
quite a remarkable moment yeah I know
you took a year out and you went to
Harvard University instantly business
there what was the greatest thing you
learned at Harvard because it's a
prestigious Business School what was the
greatest thing you learned that served
you the best you know Harvard was quite
an interesting experience because I'd
solved my business and for the first
time in my life I had something I never
had before which was time and I was
sitting at home having sold the business
and dicin thinking about what am I going
to do for the rest of my life and I
reflected back on my career thought if I
could do anything if I could change
anything what would I change
and the only thing that stuck in my head
was I'd never finished school I left
school at sixteen didn't go to college
didn't go to university and there I was
lecturing my children about how
important it was to go to university
have a good education so I just felt at
the time that maybe going back to school
would be a fun experience
yeah and that was really what drove me
to go back to Harvard but the course was
just amazing and I would recommend it to
anyone it was just incredible experience
but what it mainly taught me was when
we're entrepreneurs we run businesses
it's quite maverick
we kind of like structure we lack
organization and it's very personality
driven yeah I think the time that I
spent at Harvard gave me a much greater
appreciation of how to institutionalize
a business where you've got structure
process procedures management teams
whereas like most entrepreneurs your
kind of business is built around you
yeah and there's very little beneath so
if the one thing that I walked away with
was to the importance of understanding
that you need to have other people
around the business that the business is
not just dependent on you and that's
about you know some kind of
organizational structure within the
business where it can run without you
and most of the people I met predominate
for corporates which is exactly that
yeah they know it's not the founder
running the business it's professional
management so structure and
infrastructure yeah really important so
a lot of people that knew I was gonna be
interviewing you were burning to know if
you were stripped from everything now
with your knowledge but without any
connections without any money and you're
starting over again like you did with
your Yellow Pages book in your broom
cupboard what business would you do or
what will be your first steps in order
to make your first million and I think
one of the greatest lessons that I've
learned in my career is it is not great
ideas that make success it is great
people it's people
who make businesses successful so if I
had to do it all over again I think I
would look to back of people I'd look to
find people who have a great idea
a great product and back them to do
businesses because I think backing
talent has been probably the most
successful part of my career to date and
in a funny sort of way if we look at
what Dragon's Den was about it was
exactly that you met people with passion
desire a determination to build a
business and I think people sometimes
underestimate good ideas always find
money you know there is a lot of capital
in the market you just need to
understand how to capture that capital
so I think raising money actually is not
as hard as people think yeah it's
finding the right people with the right
proposition so you know to put it in a
nutshell
what would I do tomorrow I think I would
effectively look to back other
individuals because I don't think I'm a
necessarily an innovative or creative
that's not my strength but I think there
are people better than me with great
ideas with great passion yeah and it's
finding talent and developing that
talent yeah that's great and I think
you're in a position now where you can
do that because you've got a very
successful business infrastructure how
do you back how do you back someone if
you didn't cover the money and I borrow
it
no because when I if you remember when I
started my own business I don't have any
money than either yes so nothing's
changed and at the time I started my
business effectively on the back of a
credit card I just drew down on the
limit I had on the card yeah because I
couldn't borrow any money I didn't have
any assets I didn't own a home it was a
good example yeah that if he believed
enough in something you'd always find a
way yes and you know I didn't come up
with a strategy of starting a business
with a credit card but you know I know I
wanted to do it and then I would use any
means you know whether
from a bank or venture capital or
whatever but they wouldn't lend me the
money because 35 years ago we were in a
different world yeah and the credit card
works so if I did it again I think I'd
find a way yes that's great so when
you're looking for people because you're
known as a dragon you were known for
someone who backed people rather than
the business what key things are you
looking for in people I think the one
thing I'm very clear about is when you
build a business being an entrepreneur
is not of nine-to-five yeah you know
it's 24/7 so the first thing you because
I think some people underestimate just
how hard it is being an entrepreneur and
so work ethic for me is fundamental
because as we all know when you're
running a business whether it's ten
o'clock at night or Saturday morning
if you've got to be somewhere you have
to do something your business drives you
so I'm not sure everybody's prepared to
pay that price so when I get to know
somebody I really need to understand how
badly does he want this right so when
somebody says to me you know I want to
be successful I said why is that and
they say I want to make a lot of money
it doesn't really mean anything to me
because we want to make money yeah
that's not a drop yeah that's a nice to
have so I want to know what's behind the
individual what is driving that person
what is success mean to them and I want
somebody that can't live without it yeah
it needs to be real hunger then I need
somebody who's got an idea that's
compelling so lots of people have great
ideas but are they really compelling
right are they trying to solve a problem
that needs to be solved so here we had
crazy idea in Dragon's Den I remember
meeting a guy and he'd invented an
electric shaving brush so you know he
came and he's got this brush and the
service flying all over his face because
you know I think his idea was use the
electric toothbrush it's successful so
why don't I invent the electric shaving
brush yeah difference is the toothbrush
is in your mouth and your mouth closes
and it all stays in the shaving brush
it's just all over his face and I said
to him you know
what problem are you solving hmm because
what is wrong with me using a shaving
right it's relatively easy it's not a
problem why would I do it so when I say
the idea has to be compelling that's not
a compelling idea yeah so I want to know
is the idea compelling and if somebody
prepared to pay for it
yeah lots of people have great ideas and
they talk to mom and dad and brother and
sister and the best friend who all tell
him it's great but they're not paying
for it yes
so is this idea that somebody
independent will to pay for so can you
make it or buy it and still make a
profit so it needs to make sense and
then I need somebody who's got a vision
for where they want to be right because
if the business is just you and it makes
you a good living it's not a business
it's a hobby so if I'm looking for
somebody I need somebody who has
something more than a hobby it's gonna
be a real business yeah no that's great
I think if you've not got the money but
you've got the passion you've got a good
idea then thus I guess a bacchanal
person and I want to talk to you a
little bit about property because on as
you know a property investor that's what
I'm known for
and you've done some fantastic lucrative
deals you talk in your in your biography
about the commercial properties that you
did I think I think he might have been
the first project where you put your
money in you added value you pulled your
money out and it was I think you were
left of a million pounds which you
pulled out of the deal which was just a
fabulous deal what are you looking for
in property deals I mean the one thing
I've always found interesting is
everybody's telling me right now now's
not the time to invest right which is
the complete opposite to reality right
and the reason why people are saying
now's not a good time to invest is
because the markets down mm-hm
well surely when you're buying your buy
when it's down normal yes yes so right
now the general real estate market
across the UK is I think very weak
there's not a lot of people buying and
therefore by default that is when you
buy right it's like buying stocks and
shares you don't buy them when
at their peak yeah you know you buy them
when they're on their way down
so hopefully you rise with the market
and the opportunity yeah so now to me
is the perfect time to be buying because
when everybody else is leaving the table
that's when you get the best deals
interesting I know you store it in your
pocket and your dad said and it's a
mantra that you live by observe the
masses and do the opposite so and
everyone at the moment is talking about
what brexit we don't know what's going
to happen it's uncertain let's weigh but
then if everyone's waiting then as you
say it's a good time there's only one
thing that's gonna happen when you wait
no house will go up yeah at which point
you've lost the opportunity so I give an
example so I were sitting here in
Grosvenor Street in 2008 when the market
was exactly the same that was worse when
we had the financial crisis in 2008 it
was much worse than we are now and there
was a building right opposite here
number 23 in Grove history and it became
available as a distress sale you know
because the guy's the owner had breached
his covenant with the bank yeah and the
bank was a forced seller and a contact
of mine called me and said I've got this
opportunity it's prime Mayfair and he
said right now it's kind of 40% below
market I wouldn't have a look you know
spy chief you I said [ __ ] don't touch
it's crazy this is not the time to buy
look it's a financial crisis etc and I
sat back and thought how bad can may
forget yeah you know it's may figure to
close down I mean this is the most prime
location in the UK in my Union and right
now it's 40% under market at some point
without a question of doubt it will
recover yeah because you know recessions
do not last forever and bull market
never last River history proves that yes
and anyway so kinda long story short I
bought the building and when I bought
the building my absolute intention was
to hold it for five years because in my
head I thought it was a kind of a five
year cycle and I bought it against
everybody's recommendation
and within 18 months of buying the
building the market just bounced you
know we got over the financial crisis
you know we went through a period of you
know doom and gloom
and then it kind of bounced and what
bounces first prime it always does you
know it's the last drop and it's the
first to rise and within 18 months two
years we doubled our money you know in
prime central London so the moral of the
story is you need to buy when everybody
else is panicking yes you shouldn't be
buying when everybody else is buying
right because by default is to expire
then it's too expensive yeah that's
really interesting I know I mean you do
you built a school in Pakistan and I
know you've also partnered with the with
the with the government and trained and
helped thousands of businesses and many
start why are you so passionate about
education helping other people in
business but because you've made it
white what causes that in passion to
help others um I think if you're
fortunate enough to be successful
entrepreneur I think you have something
that it's kind of special and we spend a
lot of our time in life going through
people who are less fortunate than we
are and I think there comes a point when
all the things that we do we do because
they give us a buzz you know they give
us a real boost and I get a tremendous
sense of excitement when I can develop
somebody else and give them an
opportunity to change their life yeah I
think it's one of the most rewarding
things you can do as a human being
and it gives me a much greater bars than
doing a deal you know so when I built
the school I built the school primarily
because my father was so poor when he
was growing up he never went to school
he started work when he was 8 because
they needed the money and he was kind of
an apprentice at the age of 8 so I
happened to go
and went to the place he was born and
looked around I saw lots of kids like
him because in that particular area
there was no school which is kind of
probably why he didn't go and I thought
if I could create an opportunity in
building a school and in my head
my father was kind of very you know
prominent and I thought if somebody
given him that opportunity it would have
changed his life
yeah so it was the leaving a legacy for
him and today we have 636 children in
that schools growing and not only I
think will we transform the lives of
those children but will transform the
lives of that community because these
kids will go off and be doctors and
accountants or whatever they'll bring
back the money talk to the family and
you'll see the whole family will prosper
as a result just probably as I did you
know helping my family as I did well so
I get a tremendous buzz out of that you
know when the government approached me
to help launch start up loans in the UK
you know that was a three-year
opportunity where I kinda had to step
down from my day job work with
government to help British entrepreneurs
start the business and you know when I
went along to Downing Street met with
the Prime Minister you know he said to
me look this is what we want to do we
want to make Britain a more
entrepreneurial country we want to make
businesses kind of more thriving and we
need somebody to help us encourage
people to start their own business and
we'd like you to do that James sounds
amazing I said do I get paid for it this
will not really no and I said well can I
at least invest in some of the
businesses we helped start and he said
not really
he said that's called conflict of
interest and I said how long do I do
this for and they said three years well
I said how many businesses would you
like me to start they said a thousand
businesses
and I thought despite the fact that it
was going to take up three years of my
time three years in my life and not
being paid but I thought imagine if I
could start a thousand businesses and
help a thousand entrepreneurs in the UK
you could transform the economy so I
picked up the opportunity in 2012 and by
2015 I'd started twenty-eight thousand
businesses who employed 76,000 people
and it was probably the most exciting
part of my career because it was just so
exciting to see these thousands of
businesses being creative so I've just
experienced a huge buzz and a sense of
motivation watching other people succeed
as well as myself yeah that's awesome I
think that I'm really personally really
inspired by your journey because it's a
similar kind of journey to mine the way
you've business property now getting
back and helping others what advice
would you give to yourself when you the
the young man starting out with credit
card debt and the yellow pages
what advice now would you give to that
person I think when you when we all
start out I think we're always in a
hurry we want it all tomorrow yeah and I
think we make a lot of mistakes because
we're too anxious and for some reason we
think being an entrepreneur is something
you do overnight yeah yeah when you look
at every other career if you want to be
a doctor if you want to be a lawyer yeah
every other profession it's accepted
that we'll take you ten years right
why don't we accept that as an
entrepreneur yeah so I think when you
look at entrepreneurship it has a
massive failure rate so I think for
every one individual there makes it as
an entrepreneur if I'm honest a hundred
probably fail right so I would give my
younger self that piece of advice that
if you're embarking on this journey to
become an entrepreneur yeah it's a ten
year journey right you know it is a
profession it's not it's not overnight
success yeah that's great advice
what advice would you give to somebody
who was because I know you mentioned
earlier when I was talking to you that
if you were starting out you borrow the
money so someone who's entrepreneurial
they've got passion they've got a great
idea
and especially in the property industry
because a lot of my people that watch
this might be in the property industry
how would you go about raising the
finance from that because would you go
to family and friends would you approach
people like yourself would you like how
would you go ahead and raise that that
financed in joint venture with people I
mean I think the world we live in today
is very different to how you and I
started today there are something called
angel networks right and these are
experienced business people who've sold
businesses who have made money we're now
looking to invest in small businesses so
I would simply Google kind of angel
networks and that is a source of capital
you have start-up loans so you've got a
government scheme that where the
government will give you capital to
start a business you have something
called crowdfunding so you can go online
yeah and there are businesses called
Cedars there are venture capital firms
that will invest in startups there's
family and friends so what I'm saying is
there's a whole plethora yeah of avenues
available my advice would always be do
all of the above
right no one method can I guarantee you
yes but will one of all of the above
work probably yes yeah interesting
I like to do all of the above because
it's easy sometimes to try one or two
didn't work no one's backing me but
actually you've got to be more
passionate yeah for sure
your father was really influential I
know you talked about him in your book
and made you the person you are today
however you didn't necessarily have a
super easy time what would you advise
would you give to someone in the field
when they're starting out as an
entrepreneur because I know from
personal experience it can be pretty
hard and lonely lonely hard people say
it's not going to work it's gonna fail
who do you think you are I mean if
people can offer off the misunderstand
you and it can be really difficult to
start an out taking that initial leap
how do you deal with that it comes down
to the strength and belief of your own
conviction because what you're really
doing at that point you
backing yourself you're not backing a
market you're not backing a product
you're backing you and my advice is
don't lose that belief because if you
don't believe in you nobody else will
right so you've got to have that
strength of conviction and you know when
I was starting out it was a bit like
when I was buying property in 2008 yeah
if I'd listened to everybody else I
would never have done the deal yes
but ultimately I believed in me the
reason why everybody's saying don't do
it that's when you should be doing it's
observed the masses and do the opposite
of that I love that philosophy it is so
interesting because when I look back at
some of my most lucrative deals you know
about the castles tell you about the
castle
everyone was saying don't do that and
some of the best deals have been the
people where most people have been
saying don't do it and I think they're
trying to protect you off that it's not
like they want you to fail but also when
they say don't do it they're also always
implies it must be cheap
it must be cheap yeah because when
nobody else is doing it that's why the
opportunity exists okay right if
everybody said to me you must do that I
guarantee you it's overpriced so you
know there is a real substance in my
opinion of waiting to when everybody
else loses faith that's when you step in
really interesting sound advice when you
sold your your business I know you
sorted for a substantial amount what did
you do with the money if that's not too
personal a question I did something
really interesting because I'd met so
many people who sold their businesses
are made a lot of money and the truth is
we will go a bit crazy it's interesting
there was a study done with lottery
winners 83% of people who win the
lottery ten years later have less than
they started with before that room that
see 3% as a message in there which is we
go a bit crazy right so you know because
immediately think I'm gonna go on back
a helicopter I'm gonna quite sure a
living chance and you lose it and you
lose it I put the money and I locked it
into an account with no access for 12
months all the things that I want to do
won't disappear after 12 months yeah
okay but I need it to be real so I would
go and I remember taking helicopter
lessons thinking I'll that'd be really
fun at owning a helicopter yeah so I
took helicopter lessons were kind of
four months it was a bit of fun yeah but
I realized there's a bit of a novelty
because I never probably used the
helicopter but the fact that I couldn't
if I could have bought here I might have
just bought it there and then but I
actually took the lessons for four
months knowing that if I was gonna buy
and have to buy it in a year from now
right and actually by then the novelty
had worn away
mm-hmm then I thought you know should I
go and buy a you know a place abroad
let's go buy something in my bear or
south of France or whatever and you go
and you have a look etc now again if I'd
had access to the money i mighta bought
it yeah but I went and I stayed and I
thought but I really use this yeah how
much would I use it and the truth is I
probably wouldn't use it for more than
six weeks the year and then you don't
want to just send a hotel you know
what's the obsession and the interesting
thing is at the end of the 12-month
period which I gave myself that
opportunity there wasn't really much
that I was going to invest the money in
yeah and knowing me I probably would
have blown 20 million yeah buying houses
and boats and whatever the cases right
and the only thing I did do then I fell
in love with was I wanted to to buy a
yacht which I did and I still have one
to this day is the right decision but I
think it was a much more considered
decision right rather than an impulsive
decision yeah that's interesting I guess
it's a problem that probably most people
won't have because knowing what to do
with millions of pounds is probably but
I think rent renting liabilities and
then buying assets is probably smart
yeah rather than buying liabilities like
planes and jets unless you're in a very
fortunate situation or you can do it
with the passive income from the front
from the asset so here's a question for
you as someone who's more experienced
than me in this area as well which is I
want to talk to a little about children
you said that you encouraged your kids
to go to university which is which is
great
however I've got two young kids and I'm
trying to think how do I teach them to
be entrepreneurs how do I give them the
best start in life but something really
interesting is most people that I see
that are really successful that didn't
go to university they had paper round's
they worked really hard like I know you
had a paper round you see left school at
16 you left home and 16 and you're now
really successful same with me I left
school at 16 I had a paper round I
worked hard but then how do you raise up
the kids for success I think the first
thing entrepreneurs are born not made
there's a phrase that I love in business
you can't put in what God left out so
you either have it or you don't and I
don't think I can instill that in my
children and by not sending my kids the
university does not mean they become
entrepreneurs that's not correct right
so so you don't think give it them hard
like I'll have it and then they'll know
I guess the fire in the belly is I guess
what you're talking about but cannot put
a fire in someone's belly I think you
can so an example so my daughter yeah
you know had a very privileged
upbringing because said when she was
born I was doing quite well and she went
to a one of the top private schools in
the country went to the top university
had a great degree and has done
remarkably well so with all of the
things that you might say now the
question was though what drove her to
succeed despite the fact she didn't have
the hunger that you and I would identify
his hunger yeah but I think her hunger
she still had hunger but it was
different to ours right our hunger was
you know we need to put food on the
table and we need to earn later
you know hers she'd need all of that but
I think hers was more about recognition
and status you know and there are people
who are incredibly driven by that you
know so she joined my private equity
firm
and imagine being in my shadow in my
footsteps yeah that she is my daughter
she works in this firm people expect her
to do well and if she didn't do very
well it would be quite difficult
very driven very confident individual so
I think it's finding what drives the
individual right because I think we
can't just because something is
important to you may not be important to
somebody else so I happen to believe my
success wasn't because I think I was a
natural-born entrepreneur I was so
driven to show my dad that he'd made a
mistake in letting me leave school
leaving home at 16 so I was not actually
doing it to make money I was doing it
because I wanted to prove to him that he
should not have let me go at 16 and that
was my drive yeah you know when I
started my business and if you'd met me
in the year that I set up my own company
and said what is your ambition in life
at that time the only thing that was
important to me was my broom cupboard
didn't have a window and I was really
lonely sitting in this box without a
window yeah and at that time I would
dream about having an office that had a
window with a view because you just when
you're working 10 hours a day it was it
was really hard yeah and if you'd met me
the following year to change what is
your real ambition we'll get you up in
the morning yeah
Alison you know if I could hire one
person alright somebody I could talk to
during the day because if I had a good
core or I did a good deal can't want to
talk to somebody yeah but when you're
sitting there on your own you know so my
success has been what I call baby steps
you know the broom cupboard then the
window then hiring a person then hiring
too you know so I didn't start out with
this hunger they said I'm gonna build
the world's most successful business it
was one step at a time yeah I know you
you know really believe in education and
you've provided a lot of mentors and
mentoring been an inspiration to many
people who've been your biggest
inspirations or mentors influences over
the years
probably for me my father you know
because my father was an entrepreneur
mana business and I just truly admired
his principles and values and I think
they are so important throughout life
and I think he shaped my fundamental
beliefs and values of you know right and
wrong and and what you do and what you
don't do yeah so I always looked at him
for that kind of inspiration or that
mentorship yeah yeah that's awesome I
have to ask the brexit question about
your thoughts on what's going to happen
after that because it's such a hot topic
at the moment you said property you
think it's a great time to get in right
now while everyone's in certain what do
you think is going to happen in the
property market particularly what are
your predictions I mean I think brexit
or will get resolved for sure I think we
are thankfully and hopefully we're
coming towards the end I think the
election will be a big factor because if
the Conservatives get a majority then at
least Boris will be able to make a
decision and not be dependent on getting
a majority in the house of the
Parliament because the Conservatives
would have won through a majority which
he is clearly hopeful he's gonna do my
gut feeling is if I was a betting man I
would say he probably is gonna get a
majority if he gets the majority I think
we will leave Europe for sure
I think Boris has made it extremely
clear that's what you want to do yeah I
think what the British people want is a
decision yeah I think the country is so
fed up with uncertainty and not knowing
it's the uncertainty that's dragging the
market down yeah the reason why the
market and real estate is down right now
because we don't know which way we're
going yeah I think as soon as you will
see certainty you will see the market
bounce so if you go back literally four
weeks ago when Boris came back from
Europe and he had a good meeting about
brexit the pound took off you know it
went from 122 to the dollar to 129 yeah
the stock market rally
right and all of a sudden even in real
estate people saw a few transactions
happening okay now that was in the back
of a meeting yeah
so when we leave Europe and we are clear
about where we're going
I absolutely believe there is a wall of
capital sitting right now waiting to be
deployed I think whether it's China
Europe Asia there are people who are
looking at the UK right now I'm would
invest but are not you know so I think
as soon as you see clarity and certainty
I think you will see a bounce in the
market which is why I believe you've got
a short window of opportunity now
because if you wait and then your
margins gone yeah that's really
interesting last question and it's been
a fabulous opportunity to pick e brain
you doing a lot of speaking at the
moment leaving legacy philanthropy all
kinds of stuff of all the things that
you're doing is which is which is
incredible what do you want to be
remembered for besides been a great
businessman what's the thing you want to
be remembered for most I think miss
school you know I'm very passionate
about yeah you know I think the school
that I've built will transform the lives
of thousands of people
I think startup loads I think the 28,000
businesses that I helped create will
transform the UK economy and I think the
drive for all of those things is to make
a difference and you know if I'm in my
own little way made a difference I think
that is something to be proud of that's
right thank you ever so much for you Tom
pleasure absolute pleasure appreciate it
[Music]